where does everyone's relationship with
ferris stand today i mean are you open
to working with her again in the future
i'm neutral if she doesn't try to sell
feces over online
that was a little much for me
teen mom has always been a family so we
decided to get everyone together
for the first time ever family reunion
this is a show like we've never seen
before there's fighting there's tears
and it seems like that is just the tip
of the iceberg who do you think is
bringing the most drama this season
cheyenne let's start with you
everybody has their moment
some moments are a little bit bigger
jade
um
cheyenne
i think we had so much fun i don't know
jade what is your response to that and
who do you think brought the most drama
this season i feel like you know when
you try to handle something and then it
kind of just gets out of hand and then
it
just explodes and so i
i didn't expect that from from me
honestly i was kind of like
other things happen okay the whole show
is literally
it's crazy the whole show is like up and
down like a roller coaster
but i think there was the one moment
that i think i was really surprised and
i'm like sipping my drink and i don't
even know what to say and me and my best
friend are looking to like what
oh my god what is gonna happen thank god
she flipped over a tape because i look
crazy as [ __ ] the first day
okay so cheyenne says jade jade says
cheyenne amber
what was the most dramatic moment that
you were maybe most surprised by who
brought it
okay this is gonna sound weird to you
okay but probably me there was a night
that i felt like the girls may have been
a little
somebody was being a little rude to them
and me so i kind of went
mom like mommy mood
for all my i felt like ah no boy you
better quit so i kind of
kind of went after like some it was kind
of like saying to somebody step back you
don't like you don't do this but
honestly every single person on this
show had a moment okay
and if some of them if it was physical
drama or tears it doesn't matter because
it actually it was both it just it was
drama good night
it was entertaining but it was very
therapeutic this franchise is beautiful
like we're we're sisters and we didn't
even know it like honestly no i know
despite the the highs and the lows i can
definitely tell that there is a
sisterhood amongst you ladies and it is
very touching to watch
leah i want to get to you was there a
moment this season that you were just
like jaws on the floor i can't believe
this is happening
there were a few moments
jesus every single moment that you guys
are talking about i was like oh my gosh
what do i do i'm scared where do i go
i mean i think we each individually have
a little bit of drama in there whether
it's our personal growth that we're
going through something that we're
working on ourselves there or
just maybe some animosity build up in
other relationships with other cast
members i think but i think working
through it you get to see that and i
think it's beautiful to see each and
every single one of us grow
and macy how did you feel about this
season there was a
an exercise that cheyenne and amber and
i did
that was
like groundbreaking i mean it that's one
of the most intense
things that i've ever
ever been a part of or experienced or
participated in in my life
like game changing
that was that to me was the i guess the
the thing that tested me the most it was
very powerful
wow
all right well i feel like you ladies
have sort of hinted but we haven't quite
dropped the f word in this interview yet
and i'm talking about farah hi
uh-oh who the
invited
farah
fans are so eager to tune in to really
see what the dynamic is gonna be like
watching pharah with you ladies reunited
again i would love to know what it was
like to be back together and
was it as explosive as it looks in the
super trailer
yeah it was
um i think you know there's a lot of
people that you know
in this group that
we have really big personalities and
we're not uh one to keep uh certain
things for herself because this is a
very honest franchise in reality world
to be honest with you when she came in
it was just kind of like
she came next to me and i'm just kind of
like why
um and then you know we i really had to
you know kind of think you know
everybody had the right to be there and
farrah had the right to be there because
she was a part of the original og's no
matter what and um i mean no matter what
happened that night even though you guys
are gonna love washing it probably um i
saw a side of you know cheyenne that i
hadn't seen before but she also was very
composed um
you know i think you guys will be really
really like surprised you know with how
we did we kind of dealt with a lot of
the drama that they threw at us she
wasn't the only shocking uh
addition or
a lot of things arrived
yeah yes and we were never expecting
them when they did
exactly
where does where does everyone's
relationship with ferris stand today i
mean are you open to working with her
again in the future if there was a
potential you know return for her to the
teen mom franchise i'm neutral if she
doesn't try to sell feces over online
that was the little much for me
you're saying if she stops selling her
poop or poop
then we're yeah i don't know what's
going on to be honest with you but i
don't know i mean i'm just saying like
i'm not one to judge anybody because
like who am i to judge but
that's on a level
so i'm across your lane
drama me i have no idea what they're
talking about
i don't know how much you read online
but it seems like a lot of fans think
that teen mom family reunion may mean
that it's the end of the teen mom
franchise are you committed to staying
with the teen mom franchise or or you
can be honest you know have you thought
about you know maybe this could be the
end for me and i'm ready to walk away
i'm in this for life no
okay it's definitely not the end you
know i feel like this teen mom family
union is just a new beginning for our
franchise and this is not gonna be the
last time that we all get together we
plan on doing this again and just doing
it bigger and hopefully now some people
who didn't really take the invitation
will come
yeah
leah how do you feel i feel the same way
cheyenne builds i think that this is
only the beginning starting this team on
family reunion i think uh yeah the
show's been great to me my family and
i'm forever grateful i'm ready for life
which i stacy
don't get me wrong i like think about
not doing it every season
but
but mainly just for the kids like
bentley's getting older and stuff you
know
but at this point i'm like
son everybody thinks you're you're like
america's nephew like yeah
you're kind of already screwed i'm sorry
about that i'm in it for life too
okay amber
i don't think this is going to be the
end
it feels like it we just began a whole
new part of the franchise and we're
building from you know the middle to up
and we're going to keep on going it's
not going to stop i'm going to be like
50 doing this be honest with you
all right jade don't let us down
everybody else is still committed are
you still in it
um yeah definitely i think this last
season of teen mom 2 that we filmed was
the best season
i i've ever filmed i don't want to spoil
too much but
really watching
me and sean's like journey together and
separate
is
it's gonna be different like this season
for us is
completely different than any other
season of teen mom that we've ever done
and then going into you know this teen
mom family reunion which is something so
new i feel like this whole last year
everything has just evolved for like
our lives and i'm excited to continue to
be a part of it and continue to you know
advocate and share our story about you
know
um sobriety and you know
entrepreneurship and just being a
younger mom and there's so much that me
and sean share with our story that
i really really hope touches people and
impacts people
around the world
[Music]